all right here we go how's it going
good how are you doing very well happy
to talk with you about the movie
absolutely i'm i was just going to say
i'm it's so exciting to talk to you
because i think i've written more words
about your career than
anyone alive or dead so it's i find your
career fastening and i find this movie
fascinating i'm very excited very cool
uh so i think this is the first movie
i've ever seen where the lead actors
quote is the pull quote on the poster
where it just says this is this is the
wildest movie i've ever made and i'm
wondering if you've reflected on that if
you've reflected on the fact that you're
at a point in your career where it's
being sold because you're saying it's
the craziest thing you've ever done
i i'm not probably as surprised about
that as you are i mean actually
what it i hadn't even seen the movie yet
that was because
i was talking about the script i said
this is the wildest script i've ever
read but that transmogrified into the
wildest movie i ever made and i'm fine
with that um but
i knew signing up with sonosan that
i was going to take a trip and walk
around in his world
he's not someone you question you know
you kind of like signed up for this
different experience
so embrace it you know i call him the
warlock of
cinema i was just like
you point me in a direction sono-san and
i'm going whether i'm riding a silly
bicycle whatever you want i'm doing it
so much so that you know i was very
protective of him and
when i saw one of the early cuts i was
like no that's not
i mean i've seen noriko's dinner table
i'd seen love exploding so that's not
sono song let me see the
the original sono sonic i said that's
the movie i signed it let's go back to
that and then they did which i was
thankful for
um but yeah he's not only a great
visionary he's also my friend i mean he
invites me
and rico to stay at his house in tokyo i
mean he's just you know
it's always galvanizing to work with
someone who's an original and has a
creative mind i mean i had to compare
him to anybody maybe fellini but he's
uniquely his own thing
absolutely so as i said i'm kind of
fascinated by your process and it that's
across all your films but i just want to
use a specific example from this film to
sort of get an idea of how you how you
create i'm just you get the script for
this movie
and you see the word testicles on the
page
yeah well i knew that that was the word
i really really wanted to hit out of the
park in the ballpark
i'm wondering yeah exactly i'm wondering
how what what happens between you
reading that and then there's you know
you playing around with it and then you
getting the direction how does it get to
what we see on the screen it's it well i
mean i you know first there's trust i
trust sono song so and i also know that
his landscape is inherently surreal
um and then i hear it like music so for
me
um
my voice and my body
are my instruments and and i
so i saw the word testicle and i said
okay i want to see how
how can i extend the word
loudly
so it becomes like
like when i not that i'm jimi hendrix
but i mean
my experience of hendrix
when i first heard him
i thought it was a wall of noise and
then i got hooked and i got deeper and
deeper i went no this is actually very
carefully thought out by design
and i think i'd like to
go on record
because you're someone i can talk to
because you obviously know movies
that it's all by design it's
what one person may say is unrestrained
is actually very restrained because it's
all it's all drawn and thought out
um but that's okay because whatever
art as you know is subversive and it's
whatever anyone's opinion is is the
right opinion so but i i know that for
me
at my age
i have to stay interested and it gets
harder to do the older we get and that
means that
i've been blessed
to keep it eclectic
and
not only the genre is eclectic but also
performance style
i think the best example right now and
again i've been blessed to work with
highly creative people
i call him archangel michael who did pig
oh absolutely um you know who allowed me
to do a more quiet meditative style of
stone performance and then someone saw
my warlock of cinema
who uh allowed me to go what i like to
call western kabuki
absolutely well it's interesting you
mentioned that because i have i have
seen you say that you know you sort of
go from project to project using it as
an
as an excuse to sort of experiment with
a different
type of acting i'm wondering how you
approach that in a movie like this where
there's at least three four different
genres being at play there are you
sticking to one are you sort of blending
it together how how did you go about
experimenting when this is really a
movie that's you know a western samurai
post-apocalyptic uh sci-fi movie i
didn't i really didn't um
with the exception of maybe
charles bronson and once upon a time in
the west
i wasn't really
thinking about it
in the terms of oh this is going to be a
mash-up of styles
i was more like trying to bring my
to the best i could
my inner bronson
to the hero role
um and i think sono-san liked that he
likes charles bronson too and
but
on a deeper level
and i
i i go into these waters with you
carefully
i grew up reading john hershey's
hiroshima my dad who was a literature
professor gave me the book to read when
i was like 10.
and that really
blew my mind and it
put the hook in me
about some of my thoughts you know our
country has lost its moral ground a few
times but that was certainly in my
opinion i'm i know i can
create a bad reaction saying this but
that was one of them and um i think in
in
maybe subconsciously
well for him maybe more consciously i
mean i think hiro was
kind of
in remorse
reading between the lines
about that which is why i added the line
i'm radioactive meaning
being an american in japan
i mean they're still
you know
sorry it's my dog bruce lee quiet don't
worry so it's good to see him
uh
i mean
i mean it's understandable they're
i think they're still very
hurt but you know and i'm i'm
you know so i mean when sonosan said
when you meet nick cassavetes character
psycho i want real tears
i knew where he was going mm-hmm
well it's isn't you mentioning that you
added that that line and sort of just
like the the layers to the character
which is is surprisingly a pretty
surprisingly quiet character considering
how
big of a of a character it feels like
and i'm wondering if you had any
discussions with with shion or or the
writers about because this movie is so
symbolic it's so it's it's so visual i
was wondering if you had any
conversations you're like okay here's
what's happening here's what's happened
here's the explanation for something
that on screen is kind of unexplainable
or was it did you just prefer to play
what was that i think i
i think i
i think i knew
um
the kind of
mind at work
with sono-san
in terms of maybe the deeper meaning
beneath the scenes and i again here we
go i mean
that moment in the movie where sophia
who's one of my favorite actors ever
um were so
i mean
suit is about to explode and i do the
character does lose his testicle i think
that speaks volumes
because he's bordering on
dangerously close to sexual assault and
in this day and age i mean i think that
that is on everybody's mind i mean you
want to be very very careful
about how
we treat each other men and women we
want to be careful with how we treat
women
and i think
i think that scene is symbolic of you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna lose
you're gonna get your testicle blown up
if you even think about
you know crossing that line
i think there's some
perhaps that was at work in that
um
so there's some socially relevant stuff
going on
absolutely and so i like i said i sort
of i
i i look at the movies you do one after
the other and you know you go from
willy's wonderland to pig to to this and
then on to the next thing and i think
that the next thing up is the unbearable
weight of massive talent where you're
playing yourself and i'm wondering how
what it's like to jump from a shion sono
movie into something where you're
playing yourself and how you approached
you know i'm going to be playing a
version of myself after years and years
well these characters you've played that
is a really great question and i'm still
trying to answer it i'm
one of my answers is that i'm never
going to see that movie
i'm told it's a good movie
my manager mike nylon who's also a
producer on it looked at it and he was
very happy with that i'm told the
audience loves the movie
but it's just too much of a whacked out
trip for me
to go to a movie theater and watch me
play some ver tom gorman's highly
neurotic anxiety written version
because he kept pushing me in that
direction
you know i said tom you know that's not
really me i'm i actually have
really quiet
you know
uh
meditative thoughtful moments i'm not
this neurotic high strung
anxiety-ridden guy all the time but
that's he said well miranda cage is the
best cage
okay okay
so let's go man
i'll do what you want
well it's just i'm not i know i won't
see it but i do hope you enjoy it yeah
i'm really i'm really looking forward to
it uh i'm getting the wrap-up signal but
uh i'm
glad we got to talk about this movie and
that next movie and i appreciate it this
this was fantastic and i i again i find
your career so fascinating and i think
it's still fascinating which is an
achievement i deeply appreciate that
thanks again thank you thank you so much
you bet